ابو محمد من حي الصبره احنا اجانا اختار
انه نخلي المنطقه فاخذت عيلتي وتوجهت
لمستشفى القدس اول ما وصلت المستشفى كانت
المستشفى كلها اصابات يعني مليانه اصابات
فقلت لزوجتي ولاولادي انه احنا هنا في
خدمه الناس يعني وهبت نفسي انا واولادي
ومرتي وبناتي لخدمه
المصابين اول ليله قعدنا ثاني ليله اجا
اللي هو مؤمن شعبان مؤمن بكون جارنا يعني
كانوا اهله كلهم شهداء وفي اخت مصابه في
في المستشفى الاوروبي فظل معان وصلت مع
على اهله واهله ما كانوش قادرين صلوه فقلت
لهم سيبوه معايا انا انا ابوه واهله ما
تقلقوش يعني عندي في رقبتي كان ابو محمد
مرعين ومراعي الظروف وكانوا يعني يطعمون
وشربوني ويهتموا فيا ويودون على الحمام
ويحملون ويعني ما حستش انه حد خس علي من
اهلي وكانوا مع عن اهلي وبزياده والله
برضه اجت وانا غاد بنت من دار السودان
فمرت قعدت معها يعني لما تعافت وصارت
100% وبرضه لما انتقلنا من غزه لخان جبتهم
معاي ظلوا معاي لحد اللحظه هذه كنت على
باب الدار وبابا كان بعبي ميه بالشارع
وامي في الصالون رام برميل
متفجرات احنا بيتنا الثالث وعم ما تقابلنا
بابا بستشهد الله يرحمه وان تصوبت وامي
تصوبت ودر عمي تساوه وعمت استشهدات وبنت
عمي وابن بنت عمي استشهد والله انا كل
اللي بقوله انه احن في محنه واللي بيقدر
يساعد الناس اللي فقدت اهل